Prince Harry mauls his own brother he
accuses his father the new king of being
a liar even as a dig in his late great
grandmother the Queen the standing by
and doing nothing
from London welcome to Piers Morgan on
censored today Harry and Megan taught
what little was left of their
relationship with the royal family and
what little was left frankly of their
own reputations last week was mostly
sycophantic this latest installment was
downright seditious Prince Harry mauls
his own brother he accuses his father
the new king of being a liar even as a
dig in his late great grandmother the
Queen the standing by and doing nothing
the royal family is directly accused of
destroying two of its own to protect
itself
and I don't know where it all stops all
this
where does it end we got the book and
then we've got the interview circuit and
until it goes on
it's all apparently a dark plot by
Britain and the Royals to smear the poor
defenseless vulnerable sussexes
trickery treachery hypocrisy and if
there's one conclusion to draw from the
final installment of their Netflix
series it's the Prince Harry surely is
now a traitor to the country that he
once served
foreign
blistering attack not only on the
institution of the monarchy but also
personally against the senior Royals who
represent our country around the world
is in my view Beyond contempt in their
selfish vapid attempts to rewrite
history recasting themselves as victims
these two have sold their souls and they
sold Harry's family down the river it's
unforgivable and it will leave a bitter
taste in the mouths of millions of
people but there are toe curling moments
in this show too moments that upset even
the strongest of stomachs
if you
viewers are force-fed simpering clips of
the pair frolicking on Californian
beaches during covid in Tyler Perry's
mansion no less While most people were
locked down many in tiny homes with lots
of children
but they were the real victims not the
thousands of people dying from a new
pandemic virus
they again cry foul of course at the
beastly horrible media for pursuing them
and wanting to take their pictures
whilst persistently throughout this new
installment showing their own highly
intrusive pictures of their own children
did they ask permission from those
children to invade their privacy for
money which is of course the very
challenge they make against the media we
also learned that Megan actually thinks
she's done Britain a favor
really well let me help you
there were a gazillion critical stories
about Kate long before your beloved
Megan came along had nothing to do with
Kate's skin color
and the Megan criticism had nothing to
do with her skin color
at all nothing to do with it she just
started doing things along with you
which were rightly hypocritical and in
some cases downright unpleasant and you
both got called out for it and you don't
like being criticized you think if
anyone criticizes you they're
automatically bullies and racists
but they're not in fact one of the
people's been accused of bullying is
Meghan Markle by several of her Pas at
the palace who had to sign ndas so they
couldn't tell the truth I'm sure that
Meghan Markle and Harry who want the
truth to come out
would like those ndas to be lifted and
maybe they should say so publicly so we
can hear from those Pas who I know at
least one of them was regularly reduced
to tears
by The Bullying from Meghan Markle and
if Megan doesn't think she did bully of
course she could sue me because I've
said it now so come and see me and let's
take it to court
all of this leaves a deeply unpleasant
taste
in the mouth doesn't it and again I say
simply where does it end how much damage
do they want to cause
they can't be allowed back to any Royal
events because they'll probably be wired
up and tight for the next series of
their thrilling life story so what do
they do
what does King Charles do about his own
son
does he cut him off does he strip him on
his titles this is his son
it's a Shakespearean tragedy unfurling
and I'm afraid when it comes to help I
think Prince Harry might be Beyond it
he's been manipulated
and I think partly it's down to him as
well into believing their genuine
Freedom Fighters
to see this institutional gaslighting
your Prince Harry the Duke of Sussex
once third in line to the throne it
doesn't get a lot more powerful than you
before you decant for your freedom
before you gave up any Royal Duty
but wanted to have your Royal cake and
eat it by keeping your title so you
could exploit them
and make gazillions of dollars in
America to the highest bidder and what
do you do for that money you trash your
family endlessly and you're going to
keep doing it as does your wife who
trashes her own family most of whom
she's disowned
is this what happiness looks like Harry
really
you're happy
hating your entire family your wife
hating all hers apart from my mother
like many of the claims in the series
none of this Stacks up does it
were the claims of racism at the palace
but no evidence of who that person was
or what they actually said
apparently Megan she repeated this in
this new installment
was banned by somebody at the palace
from seeking help for her Suicidal
Thoughts think about that for a moment
who was that person are we still working
at the palace does that person exist
did somebody actually say to her you
might be feeling suicidal but it's bad
for the brand you can't get help and if
they did where was her husband in all
this where was Prince Harry Mr mental
health he never stops banging on about
it and about the need to get help and
yet when his own wife apparently had
Suicidal Thoughts he didn't get a help
does that make any sense does that sound
even remotely plausible to you
because it doesn't to me
so that's where we are another tissue of
self-serving lies mostly I suspect we
don't know yet but most of it looks like
the Oprah interview just another load of
unsubstantiated smears designed to
portray them as victims it doesn't
really pass the master of fact checking
one minute that a beloved young couple
inspired a nation the next nation is
horribly racist out to throw Megan to
the walls in the very beginning the
attacks on the Press were so wicked that
she was hated and feared for her life
but also the entire plot against them
was because they were simply too popular
so they were hated and despised and too
popular and this was all apparently a
heroic fight for family privacy but we
have to learn about that fight in a
hundred million dollar reality TV show
The flaunts their young family and
boasts about the very public social
justice campaigns Harry and Megan take
their audience for fools they blame
everybody but themselves they present
even the most incendiary of claims with
no evidence and sadly the impact
is real the royal family is getting
damaged the monarchy is getting
tarnished people are believing including
Beyonce it appeared from this series
they're believing that the royal family
are a bunch of callous races well
they're not I know the royal family a
lot of them well and they're not callous
races and they're Furious about this it
was all very distasteful peers I was
totally bored by The Whining The Whining
the whining and you know the curtsy the
things she said about Medieval Times her
lunch with the queen was like Medieval
Times which as you know is a Disney type
um entertainment place for kids and it's
just so horribly disrespectful and just
a wine vest I mean what is the book
going to be the same thing whining
whining is there going to be no positive
points and that whole thing of him
um
filming himself on the freedom flight
they must have had that deal with
Netflix done much before they ever left
so the whole thing was a setup a setup a
setup why unless you had a deal why
would you have done that filming of
yourself on the plane and all of that so
what kind of Freedom video diary what
yeah and what kind of freedom is it if
all you're doing is living in your
California mansion with unbelievable
privilege and wealth and you're signing
all these deals with companies who want
their pound of Flesh and that pound of
flesh is exclusively trashing your
family
I mean this is all they do from the
Oprah interview onwards all they've done
is trash their family
is trash but there's nothing about
themselves you know and this is a great
time for them to keep talking about
their charity but no it's about them
being these poor little children who are
so much in love and how abused they've
been their race the way they act
everything has been you know abused by
the public by the Press by the royal
family well do you know what you've got
a great life you've got a beautiful
family you're so much in love move on
welcome back I'm a lover of red meat but
my next guest takes it to the extreme
Brian Johnson also known as the liver
king that's brought his unconventional
lifestyle to the mainstream with
millions of fans but is his clean living
all As It Seems
this is what the liver King is having
for dinner today I'm having liver with
breakfast lunch and dinner because liver
is King
[Music]
you know what somebody said that earlier
you might not know this I'm actually
wearing a muscle shirt
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm making this video to apologize
because I [ __ ] up
yes I've done steroids I am a sorry as a
man can be
LeBron Johnson aka the liver King joins
me now uh well thank you for joining me
uh Brian your nine ancestral tenants
which is what's made you so rich and
famous uh our sleep eat move Shield
connect cold Sun fight Bond pretty
laudable lineup of tenants to have in
life I would argue
um but you've got to add another one now
10 which is steroid drug abuse how much
do you think that has damaged your
reputation and your integrity
first of all I deserve what you just
said and I also want to say thank you
for giving me this opportunity to come
on here to talk about this my job is to
acknowledge how bad people are hurting
today I believe there's this path
forward a better life to live I call it
ancestral living thank you for giving me
the opportunity to talk about this how
much does it damage my Integrity a lot
you know but but what I want to say is
this is um
my Integrity my my brand
um I would say that this doesn't have
anything to do with the north store the
North Star the message is far bigger
than me right the message really is
people are hurting at record rates
there's a better life to live it can be
achieved through an ancestral living I
mean it's interesting I got a text
message today from a very very famous
television personality who is known for
his own Healthy Living
um he said to me that you screwed up
with the steroid stuff but your heart is
good
you got you're a lovely family man your
views on living an empowered life
through struggle Primal nutrition Sun
ice and Community are spot on so
notwithstanding the steroid Scandal he
thought that actually the tenants that
you stand for that you've been promoting
still stand the test of time so I guess
it's going to be interesting isn't it to
see what your fans make of this because
a lot of it is down to trust isn't it
you come bursting onto the scene you're
hugely popular you're making all this
money but it's based on the belief that
your diet which is obviously very
unusual I've got some of it here the Raw
Liver they're constantly eating that is
what turns you into the person we see on
our screen when in fact it's now turned
out to be largely driven by steroids
there's a trust issue there
I understand that and I hope that we
have the opportunity to eat some raw
liver together since since you have some
there
um there's a trust issue here right and
you don't have to believe what I'm
saying but what you have to believe is
that the world is hurting at record
rates that these are the facts that 4
000 people a day actually kill
themselves that 80 000 people a day try
to do it 85 percent of the population
they struggle with self-esteem issues
eighty percent of the population
struggles paycheck to paycheck 70 or
overweight half are obese 50 percent are
on prescription medicine forty percent
however will get cancer and 20 want to
have kids and can't have kids so what
you got to believe is this these are the
facts so now how do we lead a better
life how do we get better how do we
start to overcome these issues what I
believe right and I've gone and visited
with modern day private culture tribes
in the Amazon and Africa and Mongolia
This Is How They Live these nine
ancestral tenants they don't have
material possessions they're kicking ass
in life you know so so what I'll tell
you is this I live this way before
social media I've eaten these things I
have liver I have some testicle right
here I have some bone marrow right here
um we ate this way my family I did this
before social we're going to continue to
do this on social after social we'll
continue to live this way I believe so
deeply in this that this is my why in
the world do believe that eating raw
liver is the is the real answer to to
life
you should have some too
I've got some here and I'm gonna have
some
Pierce Morgan eats liver with the liver
King you know well it doesn't not it
doesn't taste too bad I'm not squeamish
about food I'll pretty well eat anything
raw or cooked it tastes okay I couldn't
imagine living on it three times a day
but I could probably have a go final
question and we're running out of time
are you ever going to take steroids
again
so I'm currently on them right now and I
have a plan to come completely off of
them I believe so deeply in this message
the nine ancestral tenants I know that I
can come off of them I know I can still
kick ass in life okay you won't see the
same guy in a couple of months but I'm
going to leave it there good to have you
in the program I appreciate the honesty
finally well good evening from London
welcome to pay smoker nonsense so
Britain isn't feeling very festive this
Christmas it's more a case of no no no
than ho ho ho fills up we're living in a
country in constant decline war in
Europe has brought tragedy to our
doorsteps and rocketing bills to our
doormats families are being paid to turn
off their power just to prevent
blackouts millions of people can barely
afford to keep it switched on in the
first place eye watering inflation is
taking more money out of people's
pockets with every passing month
Supermarket prices are soaring Justice
was sucked into what could be an
historic recession now austerity is
looming compounded by a mismanaged
brexit that's bringing disasters rather
than dividends and far from providing
answers leadership our politics is
paralyzed by Perpetual chaos five
education secretaries four Chancellor
three prime ministers in a year
conservative parties been in power for
12 years and even to many of his own
supporters it now looks punch drunk out
of ideas and on the ropes and as a
result trade unions can smell blood like
vultures around a rotten carcass and
with a wave of winter strikes worse than
anything we've seen in many decades
they're trying to land a knockout blow
make the Grinch Lynch of the rmt is the
flag bearer for Britain strike chaos 40
000 of Israel workers are walking out
this week they refused to be interviewed
by me today as he has done for many
weeks following a series of cantankerous
car crash interviews he conducted this
morning we found out why he's got so
camera shy
you are robbing them of their income for
the coming year many of them are saying
they're going to go bust
well we're not targeting Christmas this
it isn't Christmas yet Richard I don't
know when your Christmas starts but mine
starts on Christmas Eve we understand
the anger that's caused by the
disruption of the of the stoppages of
course
um but we are getting a lot of support
from the public we continue to get
messages people continue to visit our
picket lines and what businesses ought
to be asking the government is why are
they subsidizing this strike you're just
parroting the most right-wing stuff that
you can get hold of on behalf of the
establishment and it's about time you
showed some partiality towards your
listeners and to Working Class People in
this country
because a lot of Working Class People
have been directly impacted by these
strikes Mick Lynch hasn't got any
answers it's not right wing it's not an
establishment cover-up public support
for these strikes is evaporating because
people are angry and they're angry
because it feels like Britain is falling
apart we're all being held to Ransom Now
by these union bosses nothing seems to
work anymore bus drivers postal workers
nurses Highway controllers are all set
to strike this week the Army is
preparing to cover border security at
airports taxi drivers should be used to
cover ambulance strikes over Christmas
Britain has become a paralyzed laughing
stock and we all deserve better we've
had enough of them we have all this
chaos of this decline we've certainly
had enough I think of the people who
have been putting us in this position
and his time as a country we started
fighting back